Speaker 1: So we expected that because they
said it, that as soon as any of the covid-19
vaccines got full approval from the FDA, the
Pentagon would say every military service member
has to go and get vaccinated. That is indeed
happening. And the Pentagon is mandating the
covid-19 vaccine for the military. The Hill
reporting the U.S. military will move to mandate
the vaccine for all service members now that the
Phizer vaccine has full approval from the FDA.
The Pentagon's top spokesperson announced
Monday Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin is, quote,
prepared to issue updated guidance requiring all
service members to be vaccinated. These efforts
ensure the safety of our service members
and promote the readiness of our force,
not to mention the health and safety of the
communities around the country in which we live.
A timeline for when service members must receive
the shot will be provided in the coming days.
The Defense Department is preparing guidance
to the force to make the vaccine mandatory,
with a timeline to be provided in the
coming days. Kirby would not comment
on any plans to do the same for the Moderna
and JMJ vaccine, saying the focus right now
is moving forward to implement a mandatory
vaccination regimen for Pfizer. I don't want to
get ahead of decisions that haven't been made yet.
This is interesting in a number of different ways.
Will there be service members that try to
quit now? Why do I say try to quit? It's not
always that easy to just quit the military. And
without going into all the details, depending on
what your service status is, you may be
signed on for a contract of a certain
duration and you can still get out of it. But
there are certain requirements you either need
to become physically unfit or determined to be
incompatible with the mission or in some way. So
it's not even that easy to just say I quit. Now
the other this isn't something to be happy about.
The other reality is that there are many
people that are in the military because
they got sucked in by recruiters in the first
place. We know that military recruiters target
lower income areas where people may accurately
or inaccurately assess their opportunities
in the world as not so good. And recruiters are
very good at framing a career in the military
as the best option, as a great option and the best
shot one might have at making a good living. And
so there may be lots of folks who don't want to
get vaccinated now, but correctly or incorrectly
have assessed that this is really the only shot
that they've got at making a good living. Are they
really going to quit now or try to quit? It seems
very, very unlikely. And at the end of the day, I
want to restate that the military already requires
a bunch of vaccines. This is just adding one more
now with the full FDA approval of the Fizer
vaccine. There's really no difference between
this vaccine and others that members of the
military get when they join up. You got a
bunch of vaccines when you first signed up. Now
they've added another that's fully approved. And
there's really no reason to say no. It's just the
military. This is the way it works. Basically,
every military in the world has policies
like this. Now, let me address something very
specific about the military and vaccines, because
two people wrote to me about this. I think it's
an interesting sort of anecdote to think about.
There are some people saying this is terrible.
And it's just like when during the first Gulf War
in the early 90s, troops were given the anthrax
vaccine and it gave many of them what's called
Gulf War Syndrome. Gulf War syndrome is a cluster
of symptoms that includes fatigue, headaches,
joint pain, insomnia, dizziness, memory problems
and some others. And the claim that some Makahs
troops were given an experimental anthrax vaccine
and it gave them Gulf War syndrome.
The first important thing to mention is
it's not actually clear that the anthrax
vaccine gave anybody Gulf War syndrome.
There is an unexplained cluster of symptoms
that many Gulf War service members suffered.
It has been speculated about that maybe
it was the anthrax vaccine, but it is not
proven. That's number one. Number two, the
status of the anthrax vaccine in the early 90s
and the covid vaccine today. The Pfizer
covid vaccine today is completely different.
The. Vaccine was not even authorized for
emergency use in the early 90s, it really was
experimental in the real sense of the word. It
was used off label. There was no presidential
order and it was not even authorized by emergency
use. Never mind full FDA approval we have today
is it's not even emergency use. Now, based on
yesterday's approval, we have a fully approved
vaccine period, and it is not an analogous
situation whatsoever. Now, imagine being willing
to fight and die for the country, but not
to get the vaccine that will better enable
you to do that. And I think there's going to
be a ton of I'm not getting that damn vaccine
followed by actually. You are. Yes, sir. I'm
going to get that vaccine. Thank you very much.
There's going to be a ton of that. Some people may
quit. Some people may try to quit. But ultimately,
this is just another vaccine on the long list
that's required by the military. Now, after
the break, we're going to talk about outside of
the military, the very long list of mandates and
requirements of the vaccine now that it has been
fully approved. Let me know your thoughts on this.
Is is something going on in your community, an
organization, your employer, your school, whatever
that now says now that it's fully approved, you've
got to get it. You can let me know on Twitter
where you can find me at Pakman. Remember that
The David Pakman Show is made possible primarily
by folks like you who grab a membership, we
do an extra show every day just for our paid
members and you can sign up in, I don't know,
30, 45 seconds with average computer proficiency
at join Pakman Dotcom and you can take advantage
of the discount code that we are making
available better. Twenty one, it'll apply to the
membership of your choice at Join Pakman Dotcom.